This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. not mean that you need to.
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean.
for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world, it is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. Today, we're going to talk about money, not how to make more of it, not how to invest it. We're not going to talk about get rich quick schemes or how to budget. But the ways in which money, our psychology, and our mental health are related in a lot of ways we probably didn't even know. It's been a little over two years since I last did a specific money episode, which honestly
is way too long, given how universal, I think financial insecurity is during this decade, given that it is a time when a lot of us are first becoming financially independent, trying our hardest to save, living paycheck to paycheck. I think financial anxiety is something. we can kind of all relate to in one aspect or another during this time. It kind of really bleeds into every aspect of our lives. And especially during this generation, we are facing a pretty harsh, pretty ruthless economic reality that is making the mental health impacts of our finances even more pronounced, I would say. I think at least in Sydney, in Australia, in general, really, inflation is outpacing earnings. We are, you know, paying half of our paycheck each week into rent.
Everyone wants to tell you that the next recession is coming. Groceries are so expensive. So there's no doubt that this is really contributing to a decline in overall life satisfaction and mental well-being across society, but especially for young people. In fact, I think the National Youth Mental Health Survey was released a couple weeks ago and it found that 80% of Australians, but I would actually say that this includes a lot of young people, people aged 17 to 25, 80% of them are experiencing financial anxiety. They're feeling pessimistic about the future. And they're constantly thinking about their finances and what our finances allow us to do
or prevent us from doing. For this reason, and many, many others, money takes on such an emotional role in our lives. And I just think that that fact doesn't get enough airtime. So let's talk about it today. Let's talk about the interactions between money, our psychology, and our mental health. We're going to break down where our specific money fears come from, the root of financial anxiety, our individual money archetypes, how to find out what your money archetypes, how to find out what your money archetype or money language is, what worrying about money can do to your mental health, your physical health, your relationships, our bodies.
but also how to really navigate those obsessive fears and anxieties that we typically have around financial certainty and stability, even when we are doing okay, even when we do have money. There is so much to discuss. I think I say that with every single episode, but this one in particular, this, I just know this is probably going to go up to 50 minutes, probably an hour. So strap in, guys. I hope that you learn something. I hope you enjoy this episode.
Without further ado, let's talk all things, money and mental health. health. Like I said before, money is so much more emotional and psychological than we give it credit for. Anything that we care about or that is valuable in our lives will have complicated emotions attached to it because it takes on this larger, more significant, important meaning. Money isn't just, you know, a number on a screen that represents your bank balance. It's not like a $20 bill in your pocket or the transactions on your phone. It represents. freedom, independence, security, status, a certain lifestyle, sometimes even our level of happiness depending on who you are. And we are really fine-tuned to care about it. And so it's a pretty
dominant presence in our lives. It also impacts, I think, some of the most fundamental life decisions that will make in our 20s and beyond. Like, honestly, it impacts who we're friends with, it impacts who we date. It most certainly impacts where we live, not just in terms of neighborhood or suburb, but city, country. It impacts what job we want to pursue what career we would like to have. I think it possibly influences all of those things almost as much as our personality or as our upbringing.
And we'll get to see how upbringing and money are also very, very much so interlinked. That's why I think it's really important to see. money as something that we have a relationship with rather than as just this random resource. Because in a way we do, we do have a relationship with money. Just like a romantic partner, just like a friend. Money can impact our mood. Money can make us feel safe or insecure. Our relationship to money changes and evolves as we have more of it or less of it.
It can improve our lives or really bring it down. I could be describing money or I could be describing money. or I could be describing a toxic relationship or a healthy relationship. And, you know, the same way that our relationships can be influenced by things like childhood experiences, like parental attitudes, culture, trauma, self-esteem. So can our relationship with money because it means more than we think it does. The other thing to note is that just like your relationship with your boyfriend or your girlfriend or your partner or your friend or your parents, if you were to compare that relationship,
your closest relationships to, you know, a coworker or to one of your own friends. Each of us is going to have a different set of circumstances and a different kind of relationship pattern. And that pattern is going to control and impact our emotions and our mental state in different ways. Basically what I'm saying is that this is actually a highly personal topic and it's highly nuanced. It's not just about how much money do I have. And if I have more, if I have enough, I'm going to be fine. And if I don't have enough, I'm going to be stressed. I think it's really important to note here that when we're talking about financial anxiety and financial stress,
it's actually not just one thing. It's two things. It's made up of two components. We have objective financial difficulty and then we have our subjective perceptions about our financial difficulties. Objective financial difficulty, we'll start by talking about that first. it is when you just undoubtedly are struggling. No matter who you are, we kind of all know what it means to be in debt. We all know it's not great to be down to your last $5 without any money coming in.
We know that it's a bad sign if you don't have a steady income that can pay your bills. That is when it's really time to start worrying. And in those moments, I think a lot of us feel justified in our financial worries. not having money has a lot of run-on consequences because this is not an enlightening thing to say, but we need money to live. We need it to access healthcare, to access food, to access housing, to access opportunity to be quite honest. And when you don't have money, it feels like you can't have a life. It becomes this constant stressor because it's threatening our core sense of survival. And that is normally all our brains can focus on when we're in that situation.
In fact, people who go a long time struggling with their finances, which is becoming more common, or people who have very little for a long time, even if they can meet their basic needs, if it's always this survival state, if it's always living paycheck to paycheck, they actually develop a lot of symptoms of chronic stress. Insomnia, fatigue, even stomach. ulcers, changes in appetite, distorted thinking, because all of those survival systems we have that are meant to be for moments of extreme danger are constantly being activated because money has become this important resource for which a lack of is indicative of danger. And so they tend to stay in this heightened state of arousal that no living organism, no species,
no human is meant to be in for an extended period of time. And that puts a lot of pressure on our body. It damages our immune system. It compromises how our hormones are secreted, which is something that a lot of people don't talk about, the impact of chronic stress on literally your DNA, on your ability to meet your basic needs for sleep, for rest, for connection. I don't really think it's a surprise that this one paper in 2023 concluded that having a lower income for an extended period of time, which they said was three months or more, that is,
strongly correlated with increased psychological distress and mental health concerns, specifically anxiety and depression. And the thing is, you just don't know when that situation is going to end. You just don't know when your finances will turn for you. No one can say, well, you know, on this date, you're finally going to get that windfall and it's all going to be okay. For so many other stressful situations that we go through in life, you know, whether it's like small things like exam season that might feel very big or breakups or whatever it is, we can go to therapy, we can be mindful, we can remove ourselves
from stressful relationships or situations, we can change how we think about something, we can problem solve. When you're worrying about money, the problem and the solution are the same thing. You wouldn't be worrying about your income or your finances if you had money, if you knew how to make more, but you don't know how to make more. So that's why you're so stressed. There's really nothing else you can do. Again, money is the problem and the solution. I think money just also makes life easier because it firstly eliminates the stress of not knowing if you're going to be able to provide for yourself, but it also just reduces, I guess it just reduces the stress of everyday life, of things taking longer, of things being inconvenient. The phrase that always comes
to mind to me when I think about this of like money makes life easier is the phrase money is time. And so if you have money, you can buy yourself time in your day. And I give the example of, you know, being able to order in your groceries, therefore saving your time that you can then spend, cleaning your house, relaxing, working, compared to not being able to afford that luxury and having to go to the store, which means extra stress, extra travel time, extra time, not for yourself, or not for other things that are important. And that is a small example, right? But I think it really shows how having more money does make life easier, unfortunately. The other reason that more money or a steady income or a stable income might also benefit our mental health is that money just gives
you more options and freedom to, you know, leave toxic workplaces which may have made you stressed to pay for therapy that will give you peace of mind. You know, there is this saying, right, money can't buy happiness. And maybe you've heard of that famous study that after someone is making, you know, 120K more money doesn't exponentially make your life much better. But the thing that money can get you, if not happiness, are the secondary influences of happiness. And I'm talking security, freedom, independence, better services, and of course, choice. And choice gives you control over your life, all of which helps ease stress, ease anxiety, is the sense that you actually don't have agency, that you actually can't choose for yourself the life that you want to live. Also, and you know,
not to add to this like litany of things, but I do think. think it's important. You know, not making much money, not having the means also creates limits to what we can do socially, especially if you have friends who are at very different points in their life financially. You know, how do you keep up with the dinners where it's always going to cost you more than your groceries for the week? How do you keep up with going out and paying for drinks every Friday or going on those holidays or going shopping or buying all those concert tickets. It's like with everything you're invited to, price is the first thing you have to think of and you face this dilemma. Go and try and enjoy yourself knowing you won't be able to say yes
to everything because you're limited financially and you'll probably end up worrying about money afterwards. Or stay home and get that intense fomo that we all feel so much more intensely in our 20s that not only are you missing out on this time in your life, but you're also missing out on the memories and the connections that could have been made between you and your friends. And we know that social isolation or a sense of disconnection is one of the biggest predictors of poorer mental health outcomes because we need community, we need those moments with friends,
we need to belong somewhere. I think you kind of get my point here, right? I say all of this because I want you to know, No, it's firstly not just you. Secondly, it's not an overreaction. It's not greedy. It's not obsessive or selfish to be worrying about money. Money has these impacts across all domains of well-being, even in very, very hidden ways,
even in ways that the average person who isn't struggling with money would never suspect, right? Something that really frustrates me is people who are like, oh, you know, money, every time I spend money, money comes back to me because I have an abundance mindset. And I totally respect that perspective because I think if it works for you, it works for you. But there are actually just sometimes where it's like, no, I cannot just spend money and hope that it comes back to me. I actually have a life and I have bills to pay and I may not be in the same situation as you. And I think that also creates friction in relationships where it's like money also, the way we spend money also comes down to values. and it's a really interesting touch point to see how the values between you and your friends differ,
the privilege between you and your friends differ, and sometimes that can end up being a bit of a deal breaker in a lot of different relationships. I'm going to move on because I want to talk about subjective financial stress because even when we have money, even when we can pay all of our expenses, you can still be worried about money. and I think that's something that's often left out of the conversation. And a lot of people are like, okay, I feel like I'm not justified in my concerns, but I'm so, I don't want to say obsessive because it makes it sound like this is a choice,
but the thoughts around this is so obsessive and intrusive to me. That difference in perspective comes down to our subjective appraisals about money, maybe feeling like we don't have enough in comparison to others, even if we can afford everything we need, maybe worrying about a future time when you won't have money, even though you have money right now, feeling insecure about your finances, no matter what is objectively happening.
That is the distinction between objective financial insecurity and subjective financial insecurity. And both are equally damaging. You know, I get where the sentiment comes from of like, well, obviously the person without money has it worse. But even if someone is able to meet their basic needs and still is obsessing about money, it is quite, I think, demanding and quite a burden.
And it comes from a very, I think, intricate, interesting amalgamation of past experiences that aren't spoken about. If you have had times of financial insecurity in the past, if you know what it's like to be dead broke, that is not a feeling that goes away very easily. The other example I give is if you had parents who were always, worried about money, who, you know, their incomes, their jobs meant that they could never give you what the other kids had. That is quite a powerful experience. Our brains are wired to remember
those periods of stress, whether it's because of money or really anything. Because if we've endured and survived these stressful periods, our brain obviously wants to ensure that if this situation comes up again in the future, our memory of the path out is crystal clear. That is, of course, our brains trying to do the helpful thing and create a bit of a of a guidebook for us, a living guidebook using stress as basically assigned to pay attention and to consolidate worthwhile memories. But it can also lead to a lot of rumination, overthinking about the right way or the wrong way to be spending, saving, investing, this chronic apprehension and stress even when objectively you might not have much to worry about. And crucially, this re-reactively, this
reaction is different for each of us. And this is where I really want to introduce you to this very fascinating concept of our money languages and our money archetypes. All of that and more after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory.
We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will calm out, on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people.
I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do a little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jette. And I'm Alex In. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84's big to me, not just because of crack.
I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah.
For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it.
And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely.
And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now.
In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones.
It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alesspian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young.
This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. I think we all know the deal with love language by now. this is this idea introduced by Dr. Gary Chapman, that each of us has a unique way of expressing
and receiving love, whether that's acts of service, words of affirmation, quality time, the list goes on. Well, it turns out that each of us also has a unique language when it comes to money. But in this instance, there are nine archetypes or nine languages instead of five, and they are the anxious, the saver, the spender, the investor, the giver, the hoarder, the hoarder, the avoider, the monk and the greedy. That is a lot of different labels to take notice of, but the archetype or language that most represents us is basically determined by our emotional attachment to money and how it is mentally represented in our brains. Basically, what I'm saying and what I mean by this is when you think about money, is it with anxiety, is it with longing, disdain, apathy, joy, and this will
basically dictate how you end up going about, well, you know, of course, feeling about the money you have, but also your behaviours towards spending, your behaviours towards saving, investing, all of the above. And it's really dictated by your childhood experiences with money, how your parents spoke about money, the culture you grew up in, and even elements of our personality, like impulsiveness, cautiousness, things like that. And once again, I really want to express that this is really what influences our level of anxiety, our level of stress, our level of arousal even when it comes to dealing with our finances. So let's go through these and just while we're talking about them, see if one of these really draws you in more or if you just find your ears kind of perking up,
you find yourself relating to these different archetypes or if you can see them reflected in maybe a parent or a partner or a friend even. So let's start with. the anxious, this is often the money language of those of us who grew up with very little. And so all of our interactions with budgeting, saving, financing are centered around these very prominent anxious thoughts, such as, what happens when I don't have money? Will it all be taken away at some point? What happens when the tap dries out? even when you do have a steady income, when you do have that savings account stocked up,
when you do have, I don't know, investments, assets, you still have this feeling. You still have this feeling that at some point it's all going to disappear or that it isn't going to last and that you can't get used to this state. So basically there is a lot of apprehension when it comes to this language. Thinking about money a lot, checking a bank account frequently, seeing everything. in terms of a dollar value and what the opportunity cost of that is, basically meaning what could that money have bought you and would it have been better? Some people might call this a fixation, which in some ways it is, but it's not a fixation with accumulating as much wealth as possible. It's a fixation with worrying about your survival when it comes to money,
and it really comes from a permanent scarcity mindset. In psychology, but also in economics, actually, scarcity mindset is a pattern of thinking that really focuses on what you don't have and an underlying belief that you could never possibly have enough of the things that you want and need. Can you see what kind of cycle this creates where else mentally and emotionally where at no point are you ever at peace? Even when you have money to spare or to spend, you're always in your mind kind of facing a reality of having nothing. There's no reprieve. There's no kind of break from it. So that's the first money language. Next up, we have the saver.
Now, the saver is also known as the stressor. So this person is very cautious when handling their money. They derive a lot of satisfaction from seeing their savings grow because it feels like they're doing something with it that is safe and practical. It brings a sense of security, but also because they might not be sure what really to do with their money or like the anxious, they're really worried about a time when they won't have money. But instead of that making them behave quite maybe irrationally or just fixate on the fear,
the way that they approach it is just by saving as much as they can. And whilst this can mean that they're very good at avoiding frivolous spending, sometimes they also miss out on opportunities. They miss out on instances in which they, you know, change jobs and make more money because there may be this, you know, concern that if they were to do that, that might impact their primary inclination, their primary behavior, which is to save and to save as much as they can and to make this little nest for themselves, so they never have to worry.
This is similar to the hoarder, but the distinction is that the stressor or the saver, their primary kind of impulse is to save, but they will spend when they will spend when they're they need to. The hoarder takes it to the extreme. If you've ever met someone who will literally not spend a cent on going out for dinner or buying groceries or buying the essentials that they need, that is a hoarder. It can make them really isolated and obsessive. And specifically, they are hoarding money, not with the intention to spend it, sometimes not with the intention to even allow it to have a better life in the future. It's just almost like, I don't even know how to explain it.
这与囤积狂类似，但区别在于，压力型人格或攒钱型人格的主要冲动是攒钱，但他们该花钱时还是会花。囤积狂则将其推向了极端。如果你遇到过这样的人，他们甚至连一分钱都不肯花在出去吃晚饭、买日用品或购买生活必需品上，那他就是个囤积狂。这会让他们变得非常孤立和执拗。具体来说，他们囤积金钱并不是为了花掉，有时甚至不是为了让金钱在未来带来更好的生活。这感觉几乎就像——我甚至不知道该怎么解释。
I'm trying to remember how someone explained it to me once, but it's basically just like a comfort thing. If I hoard this money, it's just comfortable to know that I have it even if I really have no intention of ever spending it. Next, we have The Spender. Now this person, actually, the Spender is one of my favorite profiles to really talk about because this person derives a lot of joy and satisfaction from seeing their money in experiences or material goods.
我正在努力回想当初别人是怎么向我解释这一点的，但这基本上就像是一种寻求安慰的方式。如果我囤积了这些钱，哪怕我根本没打算花掉它，只要知道它在那儿，就会让我觉得很安心。接下来，我们来看看“挥霍型”人格。这种人格其实是我最喜欢深入探讨的类型之一，因为这类人从将金钱转化为体验或物质财富中获得了极大的快乐和满足感。
Now, I said it's my favorite, not because it's the best, but because I just find it the most interesting and the most unique out of all of these. They really tend to live in the moment and they may prioritize immediate gratification over long-term savings, even when that is costly to them or impulsive. And the spender is often impulsive because money becomes a mean through which to manage their emotions. I'm feeling sad. I spend to soothe. Feeling happy, I spend to celebrate. So their spending habits are chronic, but they're also tied to what they're going through. So no matter where they're at on that emotional spectrum, there's always a need. There's always a reason to buy. Something to note.
我刚才说这是我最喜欢的，不是因为它最好，而是因为我觉得在所有这些类型中，它是最有趣、最独特的。他们往往活在当下，可能会把即时满足置于长期储蓄之上，哪怕这样做代价高昂或者出于冲动。而且挥霍型人格通常很冲动，因为金钱成了他们管理情绪的一种手段。我感到难过，就花钱来抚慰。感到快乐，就花钱来庆祝。所以他们的消费习惯是长期的，但也与他们当前的经历息息相关。因此，无论他们处于情绪光谱的哪个位置，总会有需求。总有理由去买买买。有一点需要注意。
A 2021 paper actually suggests that the spender is on the rise because so many of us no longer of the see the value in saving for things like a house, like big financial goals, because we kind of believe that we'll never be able to get them anyways. So why bother when we can really lean into our hedonistic tendencies? And we can kind of prioritize pleasure over everything else, the pleasure of a new outfit, the pleasure of a nice wine, of a fancy dinner, a new couch. I don't know why I said couch. I'm thinking about buying a new couch. So that's probably where it comes from. But you kind of get what I mean. Lavish trips. But it's not so much for looks. It's not for status. It's because I just kind of want to. Very counter to the spender, we have the investor. They are very focused on growing wealth
2021年的一篇论文实际上表明，“挥霍型”人格正在增多，因为我们中的许多人不再认为为买房等大宗财务目标攒钱有价值，因为我们内心觉得反正自己也买不起。既然如此，何不纵情于我们的享乐主义倾向呢？我们可以把快乐置于一切之上，一套新衣服带来的快乐、一杯好酒带来的快乐、一顿精美的晚餐、一张新沙发。我不知道自己为什么要说沙发。我正在考虑买个新沙发。所以这可能就是出处。但你大致懂我的意思。豪华旅行。但这与其说是为了外表。不如说是为了地位。这只是因为我内心有一种冲动。与挥霍型人格截然相反的是“投资型”人格。他们非常专注于通过投资来增值财富。
through investments. They kind of sometimes see money as something to play with or something to make work for them and they get really excited, maybe obsessed with knowing more about the stock market, financial fluctuations, when to buy, when to sell, but that can really make them overly focused on financial returns. Sometimes they can also become gamblers because they see gambling as an investment. Kind of like the saver, sometimes they don't actually spend when they need to because either they don't have any money because they've invested at all or because they really like to see money as this like thing to play with that can make more money, this like kind of financial alchemy that that they can perform.
他们有时把钱看作是玩耍的筹码，或是让金钱为自己打工的工具，他们会对深入了解股市、金融波动、何时买入、何时卖出感到极度兴奋，甚至痴迷，但这往往会让他们过度关注财务回报。有时他们也可能变成赌徒，因为他们把赌博视为一种投资。有点像攒钱型人格，有时他们在需要花钱时反而不花钱，要么是因为他们把钱都投出去了导致手头没钱，要么是因为他们真的很喜欢把钱看作是一种可以生钱的玩物，一种他们能够施展的“金融炼金术”。
This is very similar to the amasa, our six archetype. This is also known as the greed archetype. Some people often confuse this with the saver, but this individual isn't accumulating wealth for a sense of security, but as a measure of success and status. They are highly motivated to put money away and gain as much as possible to eventually convert into highly coveted possessions or do appear impressive to have a really cool portfolio.
这与我们的第六种原型——“聚财型”人格非常相似。这也通常被称为贪婪型人格。有些人经常把它和攒钱型人格混淆，但这类人积累财富不是为了寻求安全感，而是为了衡量成功和地位。他们极有动力把钱存起来，尽可能多地赚钱，最终将其转化为梦寐以求的奢侈品，或者为了显得印象深刻，拥有一个非常酷的资产组合。
In that way, the amassar is often driven, I would say, by ego and can become really obsessed with money as a resource for maintaining their image rather than as a resource to make their day-to-day life better. And you can see how that really ties into mental health, where the only way they feel good about themselves and about their lives is when they are growing this portfolio of what they're worth and what they have. Something that you'll quickly realize, we've only got a few more to go, but with these archetypes, with these languages, they often come in pairs and these pairs sit in opposition, so opposite pairs, I guess.
从这个意义上说，“聚财型”人格往往是由自我（Ego）驱动的，我想这么说，他们可能会对金钱着迷，把金钱当作维护自己形象的资源，而不是用来改善日常生活的资源。你可以看出这与心理健康息息相关，他们唯一能对自己和生活感到满意的时候，就是他们不断壮大自己身价和资产组合的时候。你会很快发现——我们只剩下几种了——但对于这些原型和这些标签来说，它们通常是成对出现的，这些成对的类型是相对立的，可以说是对立的组合。
They kind of sit in opposition with each other, and that's the case with the amassar and the giver. So the amassar is really looking to stock up, but the giver sees money as something to donate, to share, to be generous with, to use to help others. Think about your friend who is kind of always donating to those random go-fund mes that pop up on their TikTok. The friend who will shower you in gifts on your birthday, despite the fact that her rent is late. He was very selfless with their money.
它们彼此对立，聚财型人格和慷慨型人格就是这种情况。聚财型人格一心想着囤积，而慷慨型人格则把钱视为用来捐赠、分享、慷慨解囊以及帮助他人的工具。想想你身边的那个朋友，他总是向TikTok上突然冒出来的那些乱七八糟的众筹项目捐款。那个在你生日时用礼物把你淹没的朋友，尽管她房租已经逾期了。他在金钱方面表现得非常无私。
Often these people have been raised to be very generous, but they can also be very financially negligent and mismanaged and they lack boundaries around money that can get them in a lot of trouble they're lending money to friends to family pay me back whenever and it's kind of like well eventually you do kind of need a system around where your money's going to who it's going to so we have two more hopefully i'm not going too fast for you but you can always listen back and hopefully it's clear what the distinctions are i think when you really start to think about them it becomes a lot more apparent But the last do we have are the avoider and the monk. Let's start with the monk first because I really want to hone in on the avoider as one of
通常这些人从小就被教育要非常慷慨，但他们在财务上也可能非常疏忽、管理不善，并且缺乏金钱边界感，这会给他们带来很多麻烦。他们把钱借给朋友、家人，让他们“随便什么时候还就行”，这就有点像——好吧，到头来你确实需要为你的钱流向何处、给谁建立一套系统。所以我们还有最后两个。希望我没有讲得太快，但你随时可以倒回去听，希望这些区别已经很清晰了。我想当你真正开始思考它们时，就会变得显而易见得多。但最后这两种是我们所说的“逃避型”和“苦行型”。让我们先从苦行型开始，因为我真的想把逃避型作为我们的最后一种原型来重点剖析，这样它能给你留下深刻印象。苦行型人格其实非常罕见，但他们认为金钱本质上是一切罪恶的根源，它会让我们感到空虚，以至于他们宁愿接受贫困，有时甚至不惜牺牲基本需求。他们对极简生活非常满意，但也可能会忽视金钱的实际必要性。就像我说的，这并不常见。老实说，我觉得我没遇到过这样的人。在我的心目中和我的圈子里，更常见的是遇到那种无意中花光自己财产的慷慨型人格，他们这样做不是因为觉得钱是罪恶的，而是因为他们想到了钱能为朋友和家人做出的所有好事，而且他们对此也相当淡然。
as our last archetypes so it stays with you. The monk is actually super rare, but they believe that money is essentially the root of all evil and it makes us unfulfilled to the point where they are happy to accept poverty over sometimes even meeting their basic needs. They're very content with the minimalist life, but they can also overlook the practical necessity of money. Like I said, not very common. I honestly don't think I've met anyone like this. In my mind and in my circles, it's much more common to meet a giver who kind of unintentionally rids themselves of their financial possessions, not because they think it's evil, because they
但最后一种原型是逃避型人格，我要明确而清晰地指出，就我们这些二十几岁的人而言，“逃避型”确实是我在自己的生活中见得最多的一种。他们不想知道。他们不想知道自己的银行账户里有多少钱。他们不想知道自己存了多少钱、投资了多少钱、花了多少钱，或者接下来有什么账单要付，周末花了多少钱。这通常是因为我们即使只是想到钱、想到我们的财务状况，也会经历巨大的情绪困扰。
think of all the good that it can do for their friends and family, and they're just kind of a quite blasé about it. But the final archetype is the avoider, and let me say this, loud and clear, as far as us 20 somethings go, the avoider is the one that I see the most of in my own life for sure. They don't want to know. They don't want to know what's in their bank account. They don't want to know how much they're saving or investing or spending or what bills they have coming up, what they spend on the weekend. And it's often because we experience a lot of emotional distress, even thinking about
这里面很大一部分恐惧来自于对过去苦日子的担忧，或者是一种恐惧，觉得自己无论如何都没有受过教育，也没有能力以健康的或者对自己有效的方式来处理金钱。这其实是基于一些简单的心理学原则。逃避不良情绪，我们就会感觉好一点。逃避去想金钱的问题，我们就不会为金钱感到压力。但这样做会给我们带来极大的麻烦。我觉得这不言而喻。这最终可能会把我们带入比开始这种习惯时更糟糕的境地。因为钱还在花，钱依然在流向某处，哪怕我们没有去想它，哪怕我们在有意识或无意识地忽视它。
money, even thinking about our finances. A lot of this comes from fear, either from struggling in the past, fear and fear like no matter what you're not educated or capable of really treating your money healthily or in a way that's going to work for you. And it's really based on some simple psychological principles. Avoid bad feelings and we feel better. Avoid thinking about money and we don't feel stressed about money. But this can get us in a lot of trouble. I feel like that goes without saying. And it can end us getting us into an even worse place than we were when we began this habit. Because the money is still being spent, the money is still going somewhere, even if we're
我们在这里所做的，其实只是试图通过假装我们的财务状况中发生的一切都不存在、睁一只眼闭一只眼，来驾驭、调解和减轻我们对金钱的情绪反应。我还想说，我认为这在我们二十多岁时非常普遍，因为我们觉得自己不太懂理财，而且生活中经常会突然冒出各种隐藏的花销。我们觉得自己因为没有注意到这些而显得愚蠢或可笑。我们觉得自己把钱花在某些东西上简直荒谬透顶，或者说相当……我不知道，就是很愚蠢。
not thinking about it, even if we are consciously or unconsciously ignoring it. And all that we're doing there is trying to navigate, mediate, mitigate our emotional response to money by just pretending that whatever's going on in our finances doesn't exist, turning a blind eye. And I also want to say, I think this is really common in our 20s because we don't feel like we're very financially literate and because there are just like so many, there's just so many times when like hidden expenses come up. We feel like we're stupid or silly for not noticing them. We feel kind of ridiculous or really quite, I don't know, or just dumb for like spending money on certain things.
我认为这整个环境导致我们许多人只是感到困惑，并没有接受过关于如何花钱的教育。我们真的是第一次亲身体验到金钱管理不善带来的那些财务后果。这很尴尬，也让我们好好审视了一下自我。这让我们对自己的看法相当负面。当然，我们的心灵喜欢保护我们的自我（Ego）。它想要保护我们的自我意识。
And I think it's just this whole environment of a lot of us are just confused and not educated around how to spend money. And we're really learning a lot of those financial consequences of money mismanagement for the first time. And it's embarrassing and kind of gives us an ego check. It makes us feel quite negatively about ourselves. And of course our mind loves to protect our ego. It wants to protect our sense of self.
因此，为了做到这一点，它会阻止我们去思考我们是如何把事情搞砸的。不再去想我们的错误。这真是一个很好的例子，说明了为什么我们需要开始审视我们与金钱之间由心理学产生的这种关系。因为我认为在所有这些情况下，都有点不太对劲。有些地方略微失衡了。当我们没有弄清楚自己对金钱的情绪和认知反应是什么，或者没有真正开始思考是什么在影响我们的行为时，我们就会不断得到一个结果，那就是加剧了那种最初的需求：
And so in order to do that, it stops us from thinking about. how we've messed up. Stop something thinking about our mistakes. This is a great example, really, of why we need to start interrogating this relationship that we have with money that comes from our psychology. Because I think in all of those instances, something is not quite right. Something is a little bit off balance. And when we don't figure out what the emotional and cognitive reactions to money are, or we don't really start thinking about what's influencing our behavior, we keep getting an outcome that intensifies that initial need
在面对金钱时变得非常死心眼：去逃避、去挥霍、去聚财、去拼命攒钱。然而，在每一种情况下，尽管你可能会对其中某种原型或语言感觉比另一种更积极，但我们依然受制于金钱。我们的金钱语言仍然是对潜在的缺乏控制感、焦虑或压力的回应。
to be very one-track minded when it comes to money, to avoid, to splurge, to amass, to save intensely. In every instance, though, although you might feel more positively about one of those languages of archetypes and the other, we are still controlled by money. Our money language is still in response to an, underlying sense or lack of control or anxiety or stress.
所以接下来我想谈谈，我们如何才能以健康的态度来对待我们的财务状况，无论现状如何。以我们能拿出的最佳心态去面对，这样一来，A，我们才能在我们二十多岁时、在我们的收入范围内，尽最大努力把钱用好；B，我们才能减少一些主观压力；C，我们才能真正开始在思考金钱时落实一些有帮助、有建设性的策略，让它不再总是勒住我们的脖子，不再总是控制我们。这一切以及更多内容，就在这段简短的广告之后。
So what I want to talk about next is how we can approach our finances, whatever they may be, with a healthy attitude. With the best mindset we can possibly muster so that A, we can actually do the best we can with what we have in our 20s, with what we're making, B, we can reduce some of the subjective stress. And C, we can actually start to put in place helpful, productive strategies when it comes to thinking about money so it's not always the no
2%，这就是在有自动扶梯可用的情况下选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter），在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧、体能训练以及在我们这个奇特现代世界中建立复原力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，带大家看透那些主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾坚信种子油本质上会引发炎症。我们错了。
surround our neck so it's not always controlling that controlling us so all of that and more after this short break 2% that is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available i'm michael easter and on my podcast 2% i break down the science of mental toughness fitness and building resilience in our strange modern world all I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong.
我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力造成的。让自己经历一些磨难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何平台上的“TWO%”。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA颁奖典礼上双击（拍打）小金（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什（George Bush）不黑人（不喜欢黑人）的时候吗？我知道你在想什么。
Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking.
乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？嗯，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰克（Sam Jek）。我是亚历克斯·英格利什（Alex English）。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）的访谈，他滔滔不绝地谈论了80年代的快克（可卡因）。
What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jek. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s.
坦白说，84年对我来说意义重大，不仅仅是因为快克。我随时准备聊聊当年的快克，不过为了让你们知道我的意思……我是说，马克，这已经是我们第二集讨论快克了，所以我开始看出一条贯穿始终的主线了。我们现在还把“艾滋病”摆在桌面上，所以……感谢你把这句话说完。是的。我不认为还有比这更重要的年份了。
To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now, so. Thank you finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。请在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何平台上收听《Look Back at It》。欢迎来到我的新播客《硬着头皮学》（Learn the Hard Way），我是主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯（Kear Games）。正值心理健康意识月，我将结合我在心理健康领域十多年的丰富经验，以及与众多杰出嘉宾的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们会如此全身心地投入到追逐中，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它。而我们还在继续追逐。
Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, We get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it.
并且我们不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们总是在盯着记分牌。生活变成了一场关于输赢的比赛。史蒂夫·布恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你们觉得在这个世界上做一个好人很重要。你是个好人，是因为你心存恐惧吗？因为这是两种完全不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是的。这是两个不同层面的信任。
And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust.
我希望你们能真正地做一个好人。加入我和基尔·盖恩斯的行列，在我的新播客《硬着头皮学》中，我们将就疗愈、成长、为人父、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开免费的iHeartRadio应用。搜索《硬着头皮学》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Echard）发现自己处于一场亲子鉴定丑闻的风口浪尖。随后的家庭法庭听证会揭露了她言辞中明显的矛盾之处。由此开启了一场长达数年的诉讼之战以证明真相。你篡改了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？
I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keir Gaines, is we have. have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Correct?
我篡改测试是一次。这需要一支互联网侦探大军来破案。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税都被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士：格雷格·莱斯潘（Greg LESPN）和迈克尔·马拉吉尼（Michael Marangini）。我的脑子炸裂了。
I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg LESPN and Michael Marangini. My mind was blown.
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节季的推进，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被起诉欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。请在Iheart radio应用、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何平台上收听《爱情陷阱》播客。好了，我想再次声明，我不是财务教练。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Ameriopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Okay, I do want to say one more time that I'm not a financial coach.
那不是我的专长。所以我也不会给你具体的财务建议，告诉你应该投资什么、怎么处理你的钱。因为我相信这取决于你，而且显然我并不了解你的个人情况，但我能帮到你的是心理层面。为此，我为你准备了许多技巧，这些都是我从专门研究财务焦虑的治疗师那里、从学术论文中甚至从我自己的经历中学到的。首先，我真的希望你先注意一下，你的财务焦虑和财务困扰到底是客观的还是主观的。
That is not my specialty. So I'm not going to give you specific financial tips about what to invest, what to do with your money. because I do believe that's up to you and obviously I don't know your individual circumstances, but what I can help you with is the mental side of things. And for that, I have a number of tips for you that I've learned from therapists who specialize in financial anxiety, from academic papers, and even some of my own experiences as well. Firstly, I really just want you to notice whether your financial anxiety and financial distress is objective or subjective.
你是客观上无法满足基本需求、无法支付账单、无法给自己和兴趣留下一点余地，还是这更多是由稀缺心态或根深蒂固的焦虑财务态度引起的主观评估？为了分辨你正在经历的是哪一种，这里有三个真正需要问自己的问题。即使你有稳定的收入和稳定的储蓄，你是否也一直在为财务状况担忧？如果是，这表明存在主观财务焦虑；如果不是，则是客观焦虑。当你想到自己的财务未来时，你更多地担心不太可能发生的情况，比如，你知道的，突然失去所有储蓄？还是更多地担心真实且当前的改变？真实且当前的改变属于客观焦虑，财务未来的假设性担忧则属于主观焦虑。你有没有审查过预算，发现自己的支出超过了收入，并且负担不起基本的
Are you objectively unable to meet your needs, pay your bills, have a bit left over for you and your interests, or is this more of a subjective appraisal stemming from a scarcity mindset or an ingrained, anxious attitude towards your finances? Here are really three questions to ask yourself in order to tell which of these you're experiencing. Are you consistently worried about your finances even when you have a stable, income and stable savings. If yes, that indicates subjective financial anxiety, if no objective. When you think about your financial future, do you worry more about unlikely scenarios, like, you know, losing your savings all of a sudden? Or do you worry more about real and current changes? Real and current changes is objective, financial future hypotheticals are subjective. Have you reviewed your budget and found that your expenses exceeded your income and that you can't afford basic
生活必需品？是的，表明是客观焦虑；不是，则等于主观焦虑。关键在于，无论它是主观的还是客观的，你可能依然会感到压力。我不认为这有什么好比较高下的，但我认为根据你所处的情况，会有不同的应对策略。如果你面对的是客观的财务困难，你需要一个更务实的策略。我真的鼓励你回归财务基础。你做预算了吗？你可以和哪位专业人士谈谈来帮你管理资金？你可以请朋友或家人帮忙吗？为了让你的处境更安全，有哪些需求或消费方式需要改变？你对自己的银行账户了解多少？甚至对你日常的花销了解多少？
necessities. Yes, indicates objective, no equals subjective. The thing is, you may still be feeling stressed regardless of whether it's subjective or objective. I don't think that there's like a competition, but I just think that there are going to be different strategies depending on where you it. If it's objective financial difficulties that you're managing, you're going to need a more practical based strategy. I would really encourage you to really just get into your financial basics. Do you have a budget? Who can you talk to professionally to help you manage your money? Can you ask friends or family to help? What needs or ways of spending need to change to make your situation more secure. What do you know about your bank account? What do you know about even your daily spending?
我觉得很疯狂的是，这一代人中有那么多人在金钱方面有很多问题，他们明明赚的钱足够生存，却从不真正去看看。他们从不去看看自己到底花在了什么上面，都花在了哪里。我还强烈建议，如果情况不是你真的没钱、只是钱没花好，那就去找一位财务顾问，他们可以帮你管理债务、管理账单。这真的完全不丢脸。一点也不丢脸。那些在金钱上有挣扎、
It's crazy how many people, I think, have a lot of problems with money in this generation when they are making enough money to survive, but they just never really look. They never really look at what they're spending and what that's on. I also really recommend that if it's not a case of like you actually have the money there, you're just not spending it well. Go and talk to a financial counselor who, who can help you with managing debt, with managing bills. There is literally no shame in it. There is no shame. The amount of people who have struggles with money
或者根本不知道该怎么办的人数以百万计，甚至可能以十亿计，因为这不是一个为了让每个人都能理解而创建的系统。所以有太多的、太多的服务。其中许多是由非营利部门免费提供的，他们会让你进来，并帮助你度过你在金钱方面经历的任何难关。此外，你知道的，理财能力
or who just don't really know what to do is just in the millions, probably in the billions, because it's not a system that was created to be understandable by everyone. So there are so many, so many services. A lot of them are from the not-for-profit sector that offer this service for free that will let you come in and will have, help you through whatever it is you're experiencing money-wise. Also, you know, financial literacy
如果你正在经历巨大的客观财务压力，理财能力是一项巨大的资产。我们缺乏理财能力，我们接受的财务教育可以说是惨不忍睹。真的，简直可以说是罪过。你经历了几十年的学校教育，学习历史中的微积分，却没有一个人教你如何开口要求加薪。没有人教你如何申请房屋贷款、如何建立家庭预算、如何为开支寻找优惠、去哪里寻求帮助。但当我们拥有更多知识时，我们会感到更有力量，不再受制于金钱。再次申明，我不是财务顾问，所以我的建议相对简短。但我确实认为外面有很多选择。
is a huge asset if you're experiencing a lot of objective financial stress. The lack of financial literacy we have and the lack of financial education that we receive is abysmal. Like, it's genuinely criminal. The fact that you go through decades of school learning about calculus in history, no one's going to tell you how to ask for a raise. No one's going to tell you how to apply for a home loan, how to set up a household budget, how to find deals for your expenses, where to go for help. But when we have more knowledge, we feel more empowered to really not live under the thumb of money. Again, I'm not a financial advisor, so I'm keeping my advice on the rather brief side of this. But I do think that there are a lot of options out there.
如果这已经严重影响了你的心理健康，一定能找到一个解决方案，让你既能拥有生存所需的资金，又能拥有不用时刻焦虑、不再被琐事羁绊的资金，找到一条出路，找到一个能提升你财务状况的更好机会。接下来我们转向主观财务焦虑，因为客观财务困难确实需要务实的方法，而主观财务压力则需要更偏向心理和情感的攻克计划。
And if this is something that is gravely impacting your mental health, there is a way to find a solution that is going to leave you being able to just have the money you need to survive, but also the money that you need to not constantly be worried about it, to not constantly be hung up on things, to find an avenue out, to find a better opportunity that's going to kind of elevate your financial situation. And let's move on to subjective financial anxiety here, because whereby objective financial difficulty really requires a practical approach, subjective financial stress requires a more psychological and emotional plan of attack.
首先，我真的希望你理解自己的金钱行为和金钱原型。回想一下我们列出的那个清单，我希望你在确定了自己的位置后，去理解那个标签或原型可能从何而来，以及与之相关的习惯回路。记住，主观财务焦虑是指明明有钱，而且所有基本需求都已得到保障，却依然感到担忧。我真的希望你注意一下——这是一个非常好的练习——当你发薪水时的感受，因为那显然是金钱最为显眼、最占据我们大脑的时刻。我们手头非常阔绰。你的第一
To begin with, I really want you to understand your money behaviors and your money archetypes. So think back to that list we gave, and I want you to have, having identified where you sat, understand where that language or archetype may have come from, and the habit loop that is associated with it. Remember, subjective financial anxiety is having money and still feeling worried despite all of your needs being secured. I really want you to notice, and this is a really good exercise, how you feel when you get paid, because that is obviously a time when money is quite prominent. It's on our minds. We're very flush with cash. What is your first
直觉是什么？是立刻出去把钱花光？是逃避去看不该看账单？是马上进行投资，还是立刻把所有的钱都存起来？只需注意你的第一直觉是什么。我要说的是，如果你显然正处于这样一个时期：你正试图为买房、买车、海外度假攒钱，试图偿还债务，并且你有一个平衡的策略，那这就不属于你固有的金钱原型。你是有意识地超越了你的原型，来满足日常需求以及你当前现实中实际发生的事情，但你可能仍然有一种潜在的冲动，把事情当成情感问题来处理，而不是实用问题。所以，即使你有一个宏观的策略，我想让你注意的也是最初的冲动。
instinct, is it to go out and spend it all? Is it to avoid looking at what needs to be paid? Is it to invest it immediately or to just immediately put it all away? Just notice what your first instinct is to do. I will say if you are obviously in a period where you're trying to save for a house, you're trying to save for a car, an overseas holiday, trying to pay off debt, and you have a strategy that is balanced, that is not your inherent money archetype. You have consciously overridden your archetype to meet your daily needs and what's actually happening in your current reality, but you still may have an underlying urge to treat something as emotional rather than practical. So even if you have an overarching strategy, what I want you to notice is the initial impulse.
比如，你知道自己应该把20美分存进储蓄账户，但如果一发工资，你的冲动就是出去买买买，那么你的金钱原型可能就是挥落型。所以，当你大致了解了自己的定位后，第二步，回想一下你是什么时候开始这样看待金钱的。是童年时期的苦日子吗？是你得到第一份工作时没有接受过理财教育吗？因为只要能找出那个根源、那个起源，
Like, you know you should be putting 20 cent into a savings account, but what if as soon as you get paid, your impulses to go out and buy, then your money archetypal. is probably that of the spender. So when you kind of know where you sit, secondly, think back to when you first started thinking about money this way. Was it those hard times in childhood? Was it not being taught financial literacy when you got your first job? Because just being able to identify that root, that origin,
就能让你注意到那些感觉相似、可能会触动你、并可能触发你依赖金钱原型（哪怕它并不管用）的情景。所以我倾向于看到的一些非常常见的触发因素是：压力大的时期，我们在社交媒体上花太多时间的时候，当我们沮丧、暴躁、烦躁、经历重大生活变故的时候。我们只是没有足够的精神精力去以一种理性和有益的方式来思考金钱。
therefore allows you to notice situations that feel similar and which may be confronting for you and which may be triggering you to rely on your money archetype even when it's not working. So some really common triggers that I tend to see are periods of stress is when we're spending too much time on social media, when we're upset, grumpy, agitated, going through a big life change. We just don't have the mental energy to think about money in a way that is rational and helpful.
我们是否退回到了那种非常本能和情绪化的方法？记住，通常那种本能的方法、那种金钱原型，是防御性的和保护性的，基于你觉得曾经匮乏的东西，或者你无法控制的东西——也许是在你生命的早期阶段。所以你应用这种囤积、逃避、挥落、攒钱的方法，无论哪种，也许是为了自我抚慰，也许是因为它能让事情回到你的控制之下。也许只是因为你不知道还能怎么做。所以记下你的触发因素，因为这有助于我们理解我们的习惯回路。
do we revert to that very instinctual and emotional approach? Remember, often that instinctual approach, that money archetype, is defensive and it's protective based on what you felt you lacked or what you couldn't control, maybe at an earlier point in your life. And so you're applying this approach of hoarding, avoiding, splurging, saving, whatever it is, maybe to self-soothe, maybe because it brings things back into control. maybe because you just don't know how else to do it. So take note of your triggers because that helps us understand our habit loop.
现在，我一直在用这个“习惯回路”的概念吊大家的胃口。但这是一个由这位名叫贾德（Dr. Judd）的男士提出的概念。他其实是一位专门研究成瘾机制的神经科学家。但他关于习惯回路的想法同样适用于金钱。基本上，一个习惯回路包含三件事：触发因素、行为和结果。触发因素实际上可以是任何导致你以不理性或痛苦的方式思考金钱的事物，它会促使你做出与你的
Now, I've been kind of teasing you with this habit loop idea. But this is a concept that was created by this man, Dr. Judd. And he's actually a neuroscientist specializing in addiction. But his idea of a habit loop also applies to money. Basically, a habit loop contains three things. A trigger, a behavior, and a result. The trigger could be really anything that causes you to think about money. money in a way that is irrational or distressing, and it contributes to the behaviors aligned with
金钱原型相一致的行为。而这会导致同样的事情发生，同样的结果一次又一次、一次又一次地出现。你因为感到沮丧而退回到消费中。这就是触发因素。你手头没有足够的钱支撑到发薪水。你因为没有别人那么多而觉得自己受到了评判。这会让你觉得你需要聚敛更多金钱。现在，要打破习惯回路，我们需要在“行为”这个环节打断这个循环。当你感到有一种冲动想要立刻倒退回本能行为时，请暂停一下，真正开始关注你到底想从金钱中得到什么。我在为这一集采访某个人时得到了一个绝佳的建议，
your money archetype. And that results in the same thing happening, the same outcome occurring again and again and again. You revert to spending because you're feeling upset. That's the trigger. You don't have enough money available to you to last you until UNSQ get paid. You feel very judged for not having as much as other people. That's going to make you feel like you need to amass more money. Now, to break the habit loop, we need to interrupt the cycle at the behavior. The moment you feel the compulsion to just immediately fall back into what's instinctual, pause and really start to focus on what you actually want from your money. An amazing tip for doing this that I got from someone I was interviewing for this episode
那就是想象接下来的两个月，然后是一年，再然后是五年。你在每一个时期内的长期目标是什么？你在两个月、一年、五年后的生活方式是什么？那会让你快乐吗？这可能实现吗？你需要什么才能达到那个目标？首先，专注于让这个目标或愿景变得现实。所以要缩减它，使其与你实际的收入相匹配，与你实际的开销相匹配，
was to imagine the next two months, then one year and then five years. what are your long-term goals within each of those periods? What is the lifestyle you want in two months in one year, then five? Will that make you happy? Is that possible? And what do you need to get there? Focus on making this goal or vision realistic, firstly. So scale it back to match what you actually have coming in, what your expenses are actually
然后开始规划，稍微放慢脚步，思考一下我们现在的花钱方式是否能让我们实现对两个月、一年和五年的愿景。当你去消费、储蓄、投资，无论做什么，都要想想这最适合哪个时期，并确保你将自己的财务选择平均分配到这三个时期。当她第一次向我解释这一点时，我有点困惑。我想，你在说什么呀？但这就是她告诉我的。她说，比如说，当你买了一件新衣服。那是你的“两个月后的自己”非常非常想要的东西。那是那种生活方式。你的“两个月后的自己”会很享受拥有酷炫的衣服，拥有那些他们可能并不真正需要、但又想要的漂亮衣服。
like, and then start to plan and start to really slow down for a second and think about whether the way we're spending money now is going to let us meet that vision we have for two months, one year, and five years. When you go to spend, save, invest, whatever it is, think about what period this best suits and make sure that you are equally distributing your financial choices across these three periods. So when she first explained this to me, I was a little bit confused. I was like, what are you talking about? But this is what she told me. She said, you know, for example, when you buy a new outfit. That is something that your two-month self really, really wants. That's the lifestyle. Your two-month self will enjoy having cool clothes, having great clothes that maybe they don't really need,
所以你依然可以花钱，但当你这么做时，你还需要考虑到你的“一年后的自己”。为了你在“两个月后的自己”身上花的那些钱，你有没有同时存入应急基金，这样当一年后你的车抛锚了、你需要拔牙时，你依然能够承担得起？然后还有“五年后的自己”，你的长期投资，你的长期高息储蓄账户。你是不是只考虑了一年后那趟旅行需要的钱，而没有考虑生活中需要的钱，或者长期财务独立所需的钱？
but they want. So you can still spend the money, but when you do, you also need to be thinking about your one-year self. For all that money that you are spending on your two-month self, are you also putting money into an emergency fund so that in one year, when your car breaks down, you need to get a tooth removed, you can still be able to afford that. And then there is the five-year-self, your long-term investments, your long-term high-interest savings account. Are you only thinking about money that you'll need for that trip in a year and not the money you'll need for life or the money that you'll need for long-term financial independence?
也要考虑到这一点，并在三个时间段之间平衡你的财务决策。现在，我要说的是，五年这个时间段，我最不擅长把钱投入到我五年后的生活方式、我五年后的目标、我五年后的愿景中去了。我觉得我更倾向于一到两年的时间段，绝对倾向于我“两个月后的自己”想要的东西。比如我“两个月后的自己”想要和朋友出去吃晚餐的回忆。我“两个月后的自己”想去这家新餐厅，想买这些新衣服，买这些新书等等。但实际上，我认为这表明我自己可能也是个逃避型人格。我有时真的不去想钱，因为它让我感到压力。所以这里的关键在于，平衡是关键。我认为这真的能帮助我们
Kind of be thinking about that as well and balance your financial decisions across these three time periods. Now, I will say the five-year time period, I'm not the best at putting money towards my five-year lifestyle, my five-year goal, my five-year vision. I think I am leaning more towards like the one-to-two-year period and definitely like what my two-month self wants. Like my two-month self wants the memories of going out for dinner with my friends. And my two-month self wants to go to this new restaurant and wants to buy these new clothes and buy these new books and whatever. But really, I think that shows that I am maybe an avoider myself. I sometimes don't really think about money because it stresses me out. So the real thing here is that balance is key. This really helps us, I think,
理清金钱周围的迷宫，让我们的行为与更宏大的目标保持一致，而不会被当前的困境压垮，也不会被对未来的潜在假设所压垮。这就像是一个绝佳的系统，可以让你觉得：好吧，我知道我的钱去哪儿了。我知道它是平衡的。我知道蛋糕的某一部分没有压倒其他部分。我也真的希望你对自己的财务状况保持现实态度，这意味着用逻辑和真相取代对你处境的不理性评估。我前几天听到一个听众说，无论如何，她总是为钱感到压力。她跟我讲了一个亲戚去世的故事。她得到了大约2万美元。当然，我为她保密，但对的，她得到了一笔巨额的意外之财，她说：我一整直觉得，一旦发生这种事，我就会没事了。然而我还是感到压力山大。所以，当你开始感到瘫痪、当你开始感到不知所措时，我为你准备了一个清单，基本上可以用来确定你当前的担忧是基于实际发生的客观情况，还是未来的恐惧。如果它是基于当前正在发生的事情，你就可以解决问题。如果是基于对未来的恐惧，那么你需要管理的其实不是你的钱，而是你对钱的焦虑。所以，如果你勾选了所有这些方框，那就真的等于允许自己在发生变化之前改天再为钱操心。所以，我有能支付基本需求的稳定收入。
clear out the maze around money and align our behavior to a broader goal without feeling overwhelmed by our current circumstances or feeling overwhelmed by the potential hypotheticals for the future. This is like a great system to be like, okay, I know where my money is. is going. I know that it is balanced. I know that one slice of the pie is not overtaking the others. I also really want you to be realistic about your finances, which means swapping out irrational appraisals of your situation with logic and truth. I heard from this listener the other day who was like, no matter what, I'm constantly stressed about money. She was telling me about how she had a relative pass away. She got something like $20,000. Obviously, I'm keeping her
是的或不是。我可以按时支付账单。是的或不是。我的债务在可控范围内。如果情况发生剧烈变化，我有一笔能够应付的应急基金。目前没有任何迫在眉睫的财务危机，比如裁员或突发的大额开支需要我解决。如果你回答“是”，你可以暂停一下。你现状的现实情况是你现在不需要担忧。如果其中有一个是“否”，那么你就可以开始考虑解决方案了，因为你现在正在经历客观的财务压力，而我们之前已经讨论过一些应对策略了。但确实有出路。我向你们保证，我向你们保证。我见过身负巨债的人，把生活重回正轨，摆脱困境，依然找到了帮助，找到了成功。
anonymous, but yeah, she got this huge windfall of cash and she was like, all throughout my life, I thought that once I would happen, I would be okay. And yet I'm still stressed. So when you start to get paralyzed, when you start to feel overwhelmed, I have a checklist for you to basically determine whether your current worries are based on circumstances that are actually happening or their future fears. And if it's based on something that's currently happening, you can problem solve. If it's based on future fears, then you need to manage not actually your money, but your anxiety towards your money. So if you check all these boxes, that really gives you permission to worry about money another day when something changes. So, I have a steady income that covers my basic
我知道在这个十年里，金钱会带来如此独特的压力，因为我们总觉得不够用，因为我们才刚刚站稳脚跟。但我也知道我们中的许多人都在同一条船上。根据美国心理学会最近的估计，大约72%的人都在思考和担忧金钱。所以请放心，你并不孤单。你绝对没有落后。你在恐惧中绝对不是孤立无援的。
needs. Yes or no. I can pay my bills on time. Yes or no. My debt is under control. I have an emergency fund that could cover me if things drastically changed. There are no one immediate financial crises like a redundancy or unexpected large expenses that I need to address right now. If you answered yes, you can take a pause for a second. The reality of your situation is that you don't need to be worrying right now. If one of those is a no, then you can start to think about a solution because you are now experiencing objective financial stress and we already really spoke about some of the strategies for that. But there really is a way through. I promise you, I promise you. I've people in serious debt, pull it together, pull themselves out of it, still find help, find success.
需要。是或否。我能按时支付账单。是或否。我的债务在可控范围内。我有一个应急基金，可以在情况急剧变化时支撑我。目前没有像失业裁员或意外大笔开销这样需要立即解决的迫切财务危机。如果你回答“是”，你可以暂停一下。你的现实情况是你现在不需要担心。如果其中有一个是“否”，那么你可以开始考虑解决方案，因为你现在正在经历客观的财务压力，我们之前已经讨论过一些相应的策略。但真的有一条出路。我向你保证，我向你保证。我见过身负重担的人重整旗鼓、摆脱困境，依然找到了帮助，找到了成功。
I know that money is so uniquely stressful during this decade because it never feels like we have enough because we are just getting our financial footing. But I also know that many of us are in the same boat. About 72% of us based on recent estimates by the American Psychological Association are thinking and worrying about money. So take solace that you are not alone. You're definitely not behind. You are definitely not isolated in your fears.
我知道在这个十年里，金钱会带来如此独特的压力，因为我们总觉得钱不够花，而且我们才刚刚站稳脚跟。但我也知道我们中的许多人都处于同一条船上。根据美国心理学会最近的估计，大约72%的人都在思考和担心金钱问题。所以请欣慰地知道，你并不孤单。你绝对没有落后。你的恐惧也绝不是孤立的。
Please try and prioritize your mental health throughout this all because money comes and goes. I know I say that I know I said that I don't like when people say that. But it's true. There will be times when you're doing better and times when things aren't going as well. But your mental state, your psychological well-being is not always something that you can recover as easily as money. it is a much more fruitful investment to invest in your mental health than anything that money can buy because once your mental health, I think, really slips.
请在整个过程中尽量优先考虑你的心理健康，因为钱是身外之物。我知道我说过，我也知道我说过我不喜欢别人这么说。但事实确实如此。有时你过得好，有时事情没那么顺利。但你的精神状态和心理健康，并不像金钱那样容易恢复。投资你的心理健康比金钱能买到的任何东西都更有成效，因为一旦你的心理健康真正出了问题，
It does take so much time, I think, to help yourself get back on track. So talk to your friends about it, connect with others over their own worries, find people in the same situation, don't neglect your self-care because there is a lot that is free and affordable that is going to still help you feel great without making you even more financially stressed. You know, a walk in the park, a swim in the ocean, a guided meditation, that's all free. A yoke a video on YouTube, some deep breaths, you know, breathing is free, a glass of water is free. Money and mental health don't always mix that well, but also if you're in your 20s, you are just at the beginning. And I think the most crucial thing for you to do is to get an understanding of the ways that you emotionally relate to money during this decade.
要想恢复状态，真的需要花很多时间。所以，跟你的朋友聊聊，通过彼此的担忧与他人产生共鸣，寻找处境相同的人，不要忽视自我关爱，因为有很多免费且经济实惠的方法可以帮你依然感觉良好，而不会让你承受更大的经济压力。你知道的，在公园散步、在海里游泳、引导冥想，这些都是免费的。YouTube上的瑜伽视频，几次深呼吸，你知道的，呼吸是免费的，一杯水是免费的。金钱和心理健康并不总是能完美结合，但如果你正处于20多岁，你才刚刚起步。我认为对你来说最关键的事情，是在这个十年里了解你与金钱的情感联系方式。
one of the best tips and steps that you need for a financially independent future. And I really hope that you find it. So thank you so much for listening to today's episode. Although it is close to an hour long, I do feel like I missed some things because you just get so wrapped up sometimes in the topic and in your approach to it. So if there is something else that you want to talk about that you think could be added to this conversation, please shoot me a DM. I'd love to do a follow-up episode based on your stories, based on your thoughts. Make sure that you are following along on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, wherever you are listening right now, give us a five-star review. If you enjoyed this episode, send it to someone that you love, that you think could benefit from it. And as always,
这是实现财务自由未来的最佳建议和步骤之一。我真的希望你能找到它。非常感谢大家收听今天的节目。虽然节目将近一个小时，但我还是觉得漏掉了一些东西，因为你有时会完全沉浸在这个话题和你的处理方法中。所以，如果你还有其他想聊的事情，觉得可以加入到这次对话中，请给我发私信。我很乐意根据你的故事和想法做一期后续节目。请确保在Apple Podcasts、Spotify或你现在收听的任何平台上关注我们，给我们一个五星好评。如果你喜欢这期节目，请把它分享给你爱的人，或者你认为能从中受益的人。一如既往，
until next time, stay safe, stay kind, be gentle to yourself. And we will talk very, very soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator of available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at a podcast. For 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84's big to me.
直到下次，保持安全，保持善良，对自己温柔一些。我们很快就会再聊。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立心理韧性、健身和韧性的科学。让自己经历一些苦难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即在IHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《回望》播客中。对1979年来说，那对我是个大时刻。84年对我也很重要。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析发生了什么，并试着和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起理解我们是如何在其中生存下来的。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。
It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapy.
那是个疯狂的年份。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。在IHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回望》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的心理治疗师带来的《知难而进》，
and hosts Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the IHare radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor Star, Clayton, was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax.
以及主持人基尔·盖姆斯。这个空间关乎黑人男性的经历，进行那些在任何地方都绝对不安全进行的诚实对话，但你是和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士在交流。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲？它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在IHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《知难而进》。在2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。
You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young.
欧文斯女士，你伪造这特定测试两次了，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个女同性恋。迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的脑洞大开了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。
This is love trapped. Laura, Scottsdale police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是《受困的爱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节季继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临后果。在IHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《受困的爱》播客。这是一个IHeart播客。真人保证。本期节目暂无评论。点击转写中的任意句子即可发表评论。